I don't know I don't know what the  follow-up is so I'm I'm curious about  this and and it's generally just very  interesting to me that okay you know so  let me just show those uh two  alternative ways so here F5 yeah this is  one and you can also get the one you  were describing here as well or this one  yeah take Stakes you would take only  four we take only five black I guess  goes rookie six  yeah yeah  and the what we know about these types  of uh heavy PSN games  is that they're obviously always going  to be a bit better for white  but they're actually quite difficult to  convert definitely yeah because you you  establish this kind of a blockade you  you your piece on D7 is extremely  passive but also both of wide Shady  pieces will be heavily heavily uh  occupied with uh not plundering the  depot yeah and particularly when there's  in this this position